meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen bei wer weiß mehr mit niemand
anderem als poker herzlich willkommen
ja hallo ja und wir haben ein thema für
dich rausgesucht bei dem musst du dich
eigentlich ziemlich gut auskennen
es geht um dich geben nur fragen zu dir
passen sich gut vorbereitet wie jeder
unserer gäste bisher weil das leben ist
vorbereitung auf dieses chris excellent
also ein bisschen wie das ganze leben
ist ein quiz
hier findet es ein höhepunkt an welchem
tag erschien der erste teil von monkey
island am ersten dezember 1991 ist die
lösung an die lesung b ist am 15 oktober
1990 die lösung c wäre am ersten
september 1989 oder de fünfzehnter april
1992 wann erschien
ich bin der meinung es ist 91 muss es
gewesen sein erster dezember 91 würdest
du sagen ja ich dann locken
mai lockt falsche leider falsch weiter
falls es wäre der fünfzehnte oktober
1990 gewesen ein jahr früher ein jahr
früher
ich habe es aber erst 91 ich hab' ich
habe dem entgegen gefiebert
ich habe tatsächlich mit damals alle
zeitschrift gekauft in denen auch nur
ein einziger neuer screenshot oder auch
schon bekannte screenshots abgebildet
waren von von monkey island ich habe
jede zeitschrift versucht aufzutreiben
so hat irgendwas zu sehen war das
internet gab es damals noch nicht in em
vor so dass man halt damals wirklich
noch auf die magazine auf die papiere
magazine angewiesen war es zu was damals
absolut wirklich gekommen verbreiten fr
die steinzeit
wir kommen zur zweiten frage das spielt
er heute zeit vielleicht weil kennst du
dich dabei sei es okay
wie viele folgen hat france let's play
von edna bricht aus
du kannst es nicht es gibt ja
lösungsvorschläge a71 b 65 c 42 oder d
du kannst jede parade zum motto gott
falls jemand von euch a71 b 65 c 42 oder
d 28
weiß jemand von euch handys wie viele
folgt du weißt es ok wat mal kurz hallo
es ist okay mir wird gesagt wird würdest
du a einloggen ja jetzt ich vertraue
hier und noch länger personal voll und
ganz ganz angenehm hier warum zu laufen
ja das ist schön macht aber du hast wohl
das hat sich damit andere andere
perspektive ist wirklich schwierig oder
stellt hierfür unlösbare aufgabe
natürlich äußerst gut was ihr so befreit
plötzlich weiß ich warum deine spiele
zusammen macht es nie lieber toxizität
also pass auf 71 ist richtig
also wir kommen zur letzten frage
welchen amazon verkaufsrang hat deponie
in der kategorie games stand 12 38 2012
112 b 58 10 385 oder de 583 okay ich
weiß es in etwa in welcher region wird
liegen
ich fürchte es mittlerweile weil er so
im bereich von 300 also ich weiß nicht
welche antwort aber ich möchte dazu nur
sagen dass hüpft ja sehr stark
es gibt tatsächlich sehr stark in der
acht monate draußen und da ist halt auch
immer noch 300 etwas ein sehr guter
platz aber ich glaube das ist
tatsächlich etwas bei 300 war das letzte
mal als ich nach la paz bei 200 dollar
gesprungen sein
also 14 380 nehmen block c 350 1
leider nein es ist am 12
8 doch auf 3 583 gewesen oder 83
monja kaufen hat meine antwort richtig
wird er okay genau dieses vorweggenommen
bekommst du natürlich den goldenen
clixoom stern
den habe ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht
verdient den werde ich dir mit hiermit
feierlich überreichen
ok ich glaube dienstag gleich an meinen
einzigen punkt weitergeben
obwohl das eigentlich cool ich weiß es
mich genauso ja auch eine ehre ist auch
eine ehre ihr teilen uns den quali legen
wir schicken uns hin immer zu so
abwechselnd diesen wanderpokal wieder
einmal im jahr ein mal im jahr tauschen
genau immer mitte august zur gamescom
wird der getauschten und aber vielen
dank ja ich bedanke mich auch